the rising tide of covet cases from the
omicron variant is forcing some states
to take extraordinary measures new
mexico's governor has called out the
national guard just to keep the kids in
the classroom
80 guardsmen and women have volunteered
to be substitute teachers because so
many regular teachers and other staff
are down with covid chris van cleave is
at los lunas middle school that's
outside albuquerque chris good morning
it's a big twist
good morning schools across the country
are struggling just to stay open in
california they're asking parents to
volunteer in moore oklahoma police
officers are teaching class here in new
mexico where on any given day they need
up to 800 additional volunteer
substitute teachers right now it's the
national guard going back to class
so what is this one can you read to me
degree and diploma good job
a covid call to duty is sending new
mexico national guard lieutenant colonel
susana corona back to class keep going
and let me see if ina needs some help
over here what made you put your hand up
to say all right i'll i'll go through
the training and i'll be a substitute
teacher it's the need so
neighbors helping neighbors community
helping the community for new mexico her
mission
teach fourth grade in estancia a small
town of about 1800 an hour outside of
albuquerque what has surprised you so
far
it's actually surprised me how busy the
teachers are it's just action packed
without this intel officer these
students would be practicing reading
remotely do you think this is a good use
of the national guard i do i wouldn't be
here i wouldn't be here i wouldn't have
volunteered if i didn't think so i'm
thankful the national guard's here
they've saved the day
superintendent cindy sims says this
coveted surge has not only left her
without enough teachers it's been
devastating for her entire community
we've lost parents
of students in our school
i'm sorry we've lost spouses of our
staff
we've lost grandparents and so
we had
death come visiting because of covid
across new mexico covid is raging over
22 thousand new cases since the weekend
forcing about 60 school districts and
charter schools to fall back to virtual
learning new mexico's governor not only
brought in the guard but she too is
doing double duty as a substitute
teacher
we did math we learned about syllables
we did a watercolor art project good job
but what do the kids think about a
substitute in camo she is a very good
teacher and she's very kind she was
really fun
i really like her uniform
because i like how it has like the
patches and stuff
the guard expects to have about a
hundred citizen soldiers marching into
school districts including this one in
the coming days all volunteers are
vetted background checked and go through
a state substitute teacher training
course i should tell you colonel corona
says her big lesson from her front line
time in education is teachers are the
real heroes
and parents don't worry she didn't
forget to give out the homework
assignments nate
that's right not all heroes wear capes
that's for sure more volunteers the
better chris thank you so much